تشتهر الإمارات العربية المتحدة بثروتها النفطية وطموحها المعماري ، وهي ترى نفسها الآن كرائدة عالمية في مكافحة فيروس كورونا من خلال إجراء اختبار مؤخرًا لاختبار الفيروس في العاصمة الإماراتية ، ولا شك في ذلك هنا في الإمارات العربية المتحدة لأنهم تحكمها أنظمة ملكية ، فهي لا تخضع لتجارب ومحن الحكام الديمقراطيين ، ولديها أيضًا مستوى عالٍ من المراقبة للسكان ، ويعني هذان الأمران أنهما قادران على فرض استجابات شديدة الوحشية للمشكلات عندما يتعلق الأمر بفيروس كورونا. لقد كانت متقدمة جدًا على المنحنى مع الدول الغربية الأخرى ، حيث أغلقت الإمارات المدارس والكليات قبل انتشار الأوبئة في الصين وإيران المجاورة إلى جائحة عالمي وقبل فترة طويلة كانت الإمارات في حالة إغلاق شبه تام الآن مع ما يزيد قليلاً عن 600 إصابة معروفة و أقل من 10 وفيات تقول السلطات هنا أنها تجري اختبارات على نطاق نسبي يفوق ويستر  ن قوى ، لذا فإن الفكرة
هي تحديد الإيجابيات ، قم
باختبار تتبع جهات الاتصال جميع مجموعات شاشة جهات الاتصال
إذا لزم الأمر لتحديد
جميع الإيجابيات بدلاً من عزلها -
لإيقاف انتشار العدوى ، كلما تم إجراء المزيد من
الاختبارات ، كان من الأسهل عزل
أولئك الذين  مصابون وكسر
سلسلة الأوبئة ، إنها عملية
بسيطة يتم نشرها في
كل إمارة ، فهي مجانية للمرضى المعرضين للخطر
وأولئك الذين تظهر عليهم الأعراض
في الولايات المتحدة ، وتقتصر اختبارات المملكة المتحدة ومعظم الدول الأخرى
على أولئك الذين من المحتمل أن يكونوا
مصابين هنا.  يتم
تشجيعك على إجراء الفحص ، يكلف حوالي 70 دولارًا في
صباح الخير ، أنا خائفة
[موسيقى
] ، هل ستطلق النار عليّ ثم يصبح الأمر
مزعجًا
[موسيقى]
يبدو الأمر مروّعًا ، شكرًا لك على
النتائج في غضون 24 ساعة ، حيث
أن الاختبار شديد الأهمية لأن
سيكتشف الحالات مبكرًا
ويوفر الرعاية المناسبة ويسمح أيضًا لهذا
النظام لنظام الرعاية الصحية
بتتبع الحالات واحتواء انتشار
المرض الذي ينتقل  ht العمل في الإمارات
ولكن كما قالت منظمة الصحة العالمية
إن الاختبار على نطاق أكبر
يعد ضرورة عالمية Sam Kiley CNN Abu
Dhabi